yo what's up this fish brine okay Bryan
and Manuel okay young immigrant okay I'm
really good cooking I'm single so please
say yeah and this is my essentials this
is a an Asus Republic of gamers laptop
this is in really bad condition as you
can see let me see it looks terrible but
this is what I made most of my music I
have FL Studio on here
I've had this laptop for a couple years
and I bring it everywhere I might change
to a Mac one day but so far this does
the job so I'm just gonna keep it with
me this laptop is for music-making only
I've done this everywhere because I love
rivets cubes and I know how to solve
them and this is just like a really fun
fidgety thing that I do when I'm on tour
or like when I'm traveling or when I'm
trying to impress people mostly girls
but I try to solve it
yeah sure better make it hard that's
what she said cool
[Music]
oh it's not bad nice sigh eight seconds
I got really lucky ones 23 baby logic 5
the formula to solving the Rubik's cubes
there's a lot of things that you have to
memorize and you also have to be really
good at math I'm just kidding I'm
terrible at math because I was
home-schooled
but this is a it's just a lot of
memorization and apparently I'm moving a
lot of practice to a lot of them I spent
a lot of nights not going out and just
staying home and practicing Rubik's
cubes because I used to go to
competitions when I was a kid and then
one day I remember I was 11 and then I
went to a competition and I didn't win a
loss and then I'm like what am I doing
with my life like one way of doing this
I'm not making any money
and then that's when I started making
music so this is the Himalayan pink salt
the course pink salt I carry this
everywhere because I like salt and I
like my food salty and I also look to
cook
hit me up but you can add it on anything
like you could add it on eggs spaghetti
like sometimes if I feel like I need
electrolyte I just strangle it might
look boy and yes pink salt is really
good for you so
she got this it's really good so god
that salt pink salt it's the way to go
so this is the magnesium pills I just
found out about this a couple days ago
but this is good for your bones and your
teeth and it's also just a natural
muscle relaxer I'm a tense person
sometimes this is what it looks like you
take two a day I'm not sure if it works
but I think I've been relaxed I mean it
relaxed or just really jet like because
I'm so tired because I was in Indonesia
like literally two days ago but yeah I'm
gonna keep taking this and see what
happens hopefully this will make me more
of a more confident person and hopefully
by having a more relaxed muscle I'm just
gonna be better at dates so this is
corned beef but there's not any regular
corned beef this is corned beef from
Indonesia and this tastes amazing
I grew up eating these and I brought
this from Indonesia with me and I'm
gonna cook it whenever like I have a
kitchen because I'm an Airbnb right now
and there is no stove I looked for it
everywhere in America and I just can't
find it
this is like it tastes really good it's
probably really bad for you but it's
fine it has the consistency of like
ground beef so you just like scoop it
out with a spoon you make like little
meatballs out of it and then you dip it
in like a like an egg mixture and you
kind of deep-fry it this that's how it
works new voice this is my Bose
Bluetooth speaker sometimes when I'm
bored and I feel like I need to just
relax and just get away from work a
little bit I like to paint and listen to
Mozart on Spotify and I just I just look
at his most streamed songs and I just
like put it on my bluetooth speaker and
then I just paint whatever it is that's
in my mind at the time and I feel like
that's the most peaceful thing ever
and you know whenever I can't meditate I
just do that and it's really nice isn't
either Mozart or like Beethoven they
don't have that many of Spotify
listeners which is kind of crazy me or
Mozart I think I do honestly that's
pretty crazy it's kind of that's the
world we live it and it's kind of [ __ ]
out this one time I'm painted like just
a bunch of colors just like specks of a
bunch of colors on a canvas and then I
waited I wait for it to dry and then I
painted a big heart in the middle of it
it's like it's like a heartbreak thing
but then it's like it's really
unoriginal but I that's how I was
feeling at the time the goal is to have
every painting in my house to be painted
by me
like that'd be a tight way to live so
these are my ear pods I didn't think I
was ever gonna buy it but when I bought
this I was like this is so great and
plus it makes you look rich and I love
that
so whoever out there that thought that I
was an interesting person you're wrong
the basic [ __ ] as you can see this is
my secondary pots actually post mated
these and they work really great now you
know it definitely sometimes I put them
on where I don't want to talk to people
they feel like I'm one of important
business calls and sometimes I'll walk
around their Airport just faking a
business call and then you know not for
people to see but like just so I can
feel important and yeah I think it's a
really good investment yeah wait sorry
I'm on a meeting wait sorry what Drake
doesn't want to be on my album anymore
yes all good practicing power of now by
Eckhart Tolle I never read books first
of all this is like the second book I've
ever read this is about living in the
moment because that's what I struggle
with and that's what I'm like trying to
do a lot more these days I'm just kind
of like this book says like a lot of
simple [ __ ] that like and when you see
it you're like oh that's crazy like I'm
gonna do that now but it's like a lot of
simple stuff but it's worded so in a way
that like when you see it you're like oh
that makes something make sense
like I'm not anxious anymore or like I'm
so in the moment now so I just bring
this everywhere
it's kind of you know try to live in the
moment as much as I can not wait too
much about the pass in the future you
should go
[Music]
this is an iPhone 8 and this is where I
do a lot of things with this I'm going
Twitter you know I post my thoughts and
I post selfies of myself and talk to my
family on this most important thing I
write music on this
sometimes when I'm outside or like I
hear people talking and then they
somebody says something and I'm like oh
that's really cool it's a really cool
sentence I'm gonna write it down and
then later when I'm in the studio no
wait a song I can go back to life just
let stuff like cool sentences and words
it's kind of funny because there's some
like really deep stuff in here but then
there's also like really stupid [ __ ] so
I'm gonna read your couple I want to be
great but I'm too scared to die yeah
I'll write P grumpy castles let me think
of another D point I haven't reached my
end goal but I'm not far from it a recto
patron huh let me know which one you
want me to make full songs oh this is a
nail clipper and I bring it everywhere
what about like your hand nail clipper
are you serious what that's crazy but I
had no idea I've been just like cutting
my nails with this my whole life and I
don't know if it's like an Indonesian
thing or what be like this is what
people use and how small is the hand
nail pepper
well you know this is this is my culture
and this is who I am and I'm rich Brian
and this is my story this is a arouse
award card I I go to Ralph's quite a bit
for cuz you know I got said I cook a lot
and I'd like it just saves me a lot of
money it's nice it like I always do
stuff check out - I never like wait in
line for check out I don't know ever
since I found out about self check out
I'm like oh wow this is I'm in America
this is tight I will that's it guys
these are all my essentials and yeah
don't forget to check on my oven to
Saylor it's out now it's really good
album make sure you listen to it and buy
it